هذه هي اللحظة التي هرب فيها القاتل المدان
دانيلو كافالكانتي من
سجن مقاطعة تشيستر في ولاية بنسلفانيا، مما أدى إلى
مطاردة مكثفة أصبحت الآن في
يومها السابع من منطقة التمرين، حيث
سار السلطعون على الحائط
وسقط على ما يبدو على الجانب الآخر من
هروب كافكانتي من السجن وهو يحمل سرطان البحر.
صعد جدارًا ودفع طريقه عبر
سلك شائك وركض عبر السطح وتسلق سياجًا آخر وشق طريقه عبر
المزيد من الأسلاك الشائكة، ولم يتمكن حارس البرج في
مركز المراقبة من رؤية الهروب وتم
وضعه في إجازة إدارية
واستغرق الأمر ساعة حتى  تم
إغلاق السجن وتم إطلاق إنذار،
علاوة على ذلك، اعترفت السلطات في مايو/أيار بأن
سجينًا آخر هرب لفترة وجيزة بنفس
الطريق منذ ذلك الحين، وكانت
الخطوة الوحيدة المتخذة لمعالجة نقطة الضعف
هي تركيب سلك شائك إضافي جيدًا،
ونعتقد أن الإجراءات الأمنية التي
اتخذناها  كانت كافية، لقد أثبتوا
خلاف ذلك في هذه الأثناء، تنمو منطقة البحث
مرة أخرى اليوم بعد
رؤية أخرى تم الإبلاغ عنها الليلة الماضية على عكس
رؤية يوم الاثنين في
قاع جدول من قبل أحد السكان لم يتم التقاطها
بالكاميرا وهو يتتبع أثرًا له
في أي مكان، نعم كانت هناك آثار أقدام
وكانت هناك مؤشرات أخرى
لنا على أنه مر عبر
منطقة معينة، حيث أرسلنا عددًا من الكلاب
مسارات اتبعناها
لبعض الوقت، حيث يواصل مئات الضباط
بالإضافة إلى الكلاب والطائرات بدون طيار والمروحيات
البحث عند حواجز الطرق و
لاحظت سي إن إن أن الشرطة تقوم
بتفتيش المركبات وفتح
الصناديق والتحقق من المقاعد الخلفية، فسوف يرتكب هذا
الخطأ المتمثل في أننا ندفعه بقوة حتى
يرتكبه أو سيكون هناك
نوع آخر من الأدلة التي
توجهنا إليه في منطقتين مدرسيتين
مرة أخرى  مغلق اليوم، مكالمات عكسية 9-1-1
تحذر السكان في المنطقة إذا رأيت
هذا الشخص فلا تقترب منه،
أغلق كل شيء، أغلق السيارات
ليلاً، لقد قمت بفحص جميع
الغابات من خطر أنه
شخص عنيف إذا أتيحت له الفرصة
أعتقد أنه سيستخدم أكبر قدر ممكن من العنف الذي
يحتاجه أو يستطيع تجنب القبض على
كافالكانتي الهارب يوم الخميس الماضي بعد ما يزيد
قليلاً عن أسبوع من الحكم عليه بالسجن مدى
الحياة دون الإفراج المشروط بتهمة
قتل صديقته السابقة ديبورا
براندو عام 2021، وتقول السلطات إنها اكتشفت
أنه  كانت مطلوبة بتهم القتل في
البرازيل، وقالت شقيقتها لشبكة CNN إنه
أصبح مشبوهًا وغيورًا، وكانت
هناك تهديدات مثل إذا خدعتني يومًا ما،
سأفعل لك أسوأ ما في
هذه الأنواع من الأشياء الآن بعد أن
هرب، فهي خائفة
ولم أفعل ذلك.  نمت لعدة أيام منذ ذلك الحين، ثم
غفوت وأستيقظت خائفًا
الآن بينما يشعر مسؤولو إنفاذ القانون بالقلق من
أن هذه المطاردة يمكن أن تصل
إلى نهاية عنيفة نظرًا
لتاريخ دانيلو كافالكانتي العنيف، أخبرني
المقدم جورج بيفينز من
شرطة ولاية بنسلفانيا
الآن أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لديهم أي مؤشر على أنه
يحمل سلاحًا ولكنهم
يشعرون بالقلق من إمكانية حصوله على سلاح وقد
شوهد بالقرب من عدة منازل
أجنبية